...all the way from Switzerland -
here's Frida.
Hello.
-Welcome.
-Thank you.
When it was known that you'd be here,
we started getting calls from all over.
-It's really...
-Good thing you're answer them...
I've been on the phone the whole week,
but...
They all call to know when we'll hear
some new music from you.
I've learnt never to say never.
You just don't know.
But I've reached an age when you start
taking it easier.
But I enjoy singing.
I still sing - at home.
I've done a small experiment.
I live in Zermatt.
And next year, Zermatt will celebrate
the 150th anniversary-
-of the first ascent of the Matterhorn.
-That big mountain.
-Right.
So, we've organized a tribute
to the Matterhorn.
It's us and some German producers
and sound engineers.
-So, it's a song about...
-About Matterhorn.
It's called "1865".
That's when the first ascent took place.
-And you're singing.
-I'm participating in it, yes.
-And how's that working out?
-I don't remember right now.
-It will be released in December.
-Is it "Ain't No Mountain high enough"?
No, it's not that type of song.
It's cuter.
The mountains are
very important to you.
-You live in Switzerland.
-Yes.
I've thought about it. I was born
in the mountains, near Narvik.
There are some very high
mountains there too.
It's as if the circle's closed now.
I'm back in the nature where I was born.
I'm very happy in the mountains.
I like sports, hiking, skiing,
mountain-climbing...
Well, I don't do that too often anymore.
Everything connected to nature-
-gives me peace of mind.
-How much of a Swiss are you now?
-I feel at home there.
I've lived in Switzerland
for 30 years now.
It's almost as long as I lived in
Scandinavia, soon, in a couple of years.
So...yes.
I also know, that when you're
not climbing mountains...
It's been a couple of years now...
Not anymore.
One thing we learnt
during the research...
-...was that you write a lot.
-Yes.
I've always written a lot, even though
I haven't published anything.
But I've had to write my thoughts
out of my system-
-at times in my life when things
have been a bit harder.
Today, my writing is more focused
on telling a story-
-rather than exploring my life.
But I've involved myself - as an animal,
however. I won't tell you which animal.
And I find this very exciting.
I want to write a story
with ecological overtones-
-since I've spent a lot of time working
on this before-
-and still feel close to nature.
When you say you've dealt
with difficult things in your life...
There's a Norwegian expression: "You've
been out during the winter's nights."
-Yes.
-You've suffered great hardships.
You've had to start over quite often.
You're twice divorced.
And you've been left a widow. And you
lost your daughter in an accident.
And you've moved around a lot.
You were born in Norway.
-But you didn't stay there very long.
-No.
I lived there until I was two years old.
Excuse me.
The person who started my nomadic life
was my grandmother.
She's the one who brought me
to Sweden. She'd lost her husband.
She had six children
who'd already left home.
She wanted to start over,
so she brought me with her.
My mother had to move somewhere
else in Norway to earn a living...
-Your father was a German soldier.
-Exactly.
-He wasn't in the picture.
-Not easy in Norway.
No, it wasn't. I can't describe the
situation back then, as I was so young.
But she moved to Sweden and got a job-
-and that's how my nomadic life began.
I have moved quite a lot.
Things have improved now.
I used to get restless if I stayed too
long in one place. It's in my blood.
What are your thoughts
on this breaking up and moving-
-that you were into earlier?
How has this influenced
your personality?
It may have led to a certain degree
of loneliness.
A travelling nomad is relatively lonely.
This has accompanied me through life.
A loneliness that I sometimes would
find troublesome-
-but that I've come to enjoy
quite a lot now.
Solitude has become my companion.
You told us about your grandmother
who was Norwegian.
Where I grew up, we...
Maybe it was a bit too emphasized-
-that you were Norwegian.
So, even if you were unaware of this,
ABBA was a Norwegian-Swedish band.
It was a huge Norwegian-Swedish success,
and abroad we'd say:
"They are Norwegian.
Yes, they are Norwegian."
-So you bragged about me?
-You were my only joker abroad.
-But...
-I'll disappoint you now.
I applied for Swedish citizenship
when I was sixteen years old.
I've been a Swede ever since.
If ever you were to change your mind
I'm sure you'd be welcome here.
But... Your grandmother.
Today you're a grandmother yourself.
-Yes.
-Are you like her?
-Well...
-She was an important person.